the jurogan experience well which with
saturday night live was the first time
of uh
oh i also did uh
i did a pilot
i was out in l.a
to audition for one pilot i didn't get
and then a friend of mine a comic
said i'm in this pilot uh you want to
come and audition with me
for it i'm already in it and
and i got that nev it never had it was
terrible
and um
that oh that one was called the uh
the adventures of uh wally brown
and the the one of the actors just died
recently um
peter scalari oh the guy from uh bosom
buddies yeah yeah oh
wow and so he was one of the stars of
that wow and but that was my first time
of i don't remember how much i got but
getting a check and going wow this is
actual money so was snl before or after
that uh uh that was uh snl was after and
was you said snl was terrible
uh yeah the seat well the season i was
on
uh
like the original well lorne michaels
left and the original cast left oh
really so people hated the show before
it even got on the edge lauren michaels
left at one point yeah i did yeah yeah
he came back yeah
uh then they got they got in dick
ebersole was the next one
and uh
well no i think ebersole was after my
season my season was gene dominion
and but
the idea back then
of uh
saturday night live with different cast
members that just wasn't now it's like
the cash changes every five minutes
right
but back then it was like no we could it
would be like saying
like in the middle of beatlemania that
uh oh we're getting four other guys to
be the beatles or or when friends was on
we're recasting friends but just watch
it same way
and so they were
they were news stories and articles
saying how dare they this was sacrilege
so
that's funny so you were like the second
cast
uh yeah we were the second cast and
and it's like everybody left
uh yeah yeah all the original people
were gone
and
it was like
uh
see you you don't want to be the
replacement you want to be the
replacement of the replacement
because then you get one guy that's the
sacrificial lamb
that they throw into the fire and then
next it's like oh well it's better than
that other guy
yeah yeah right you then you come in
after you and then you could actually be
accepted yeah slightly
god damn did you enjoy the like the
process at all and not really and i i
was
uh
nothing new i was always weird
[Laughter]
um
when i was auditioning there were
a few additions some
at a comedy club
others in their office
and they would be like lots of people
there and i would hear you know other
people who auditioned who would say oh
they were so hateful of everybody else
who was against them in there
and i remember just out of weirdness not
courage out of weirdness i
i didn't take auditioning
for saturday night live as something
important i don't know why i just didn't
and i would go there and do bits and
everything
and when i was on it i didn't feel like
well i mean there was a reason i didn't
feel like a star there because everyone
was torn to shreds in the press
but and then when i got fired from it
i you know thought okay
oh the way i got fired from saturday
night live there used to be a
a table there that they would throw fan
letters when there was a such thing as
fan letters
now it's you know who writes a fan
letter anymore it's all uh
you know emails stuff
uh and that they so
i was waiting they had fired or the
producer
and
uh dick ebersole came in he said all
right well we're just going to make
changes here and there nothing major uh
come in next week and uh we'll discuss
it and they were taking people in one by
one and i'm waiting there and killing
time i see a
a
girl
writes a fan letter to me from like
omaha whatever
and i open it up before i even get into
the office i open the letter and it
starts off dear gilbert i'm so sorry
about what happened to you
so i found out from a fan letter from
some uh 15 year old girl how did she
find out yeah i don't know but maybe she
saw it coming yeah yeah
and she started writing it after the
first episode oh
the writing's on the wall yeah
this guy sucks
was it the same kind of environment
because the thing about saturn live that
i keep hearing from former cast members
is that it was like a dog-eat-dog world
over there and people would be
backstabbing people and stealing their
their ideas for sketches uh yeah jim
brewer had a horrible time there yeah
i remember well i remember like i didn't
like the writers and the writers hated
me
and
so one time to prove it how much they
hated me they wrote a funeral sketch
where i was the dead body so i just had
to lie there in the coffin that's it
yeah
wow
just to [ __ ] you yeah
yeah that the the environment phil
hartman said the same thing he said the
environment over there was just toxic
like everybody was like at each other's
throats and just wasn't fun they were
always like
just hamstringing each other yeah always
trying to [ __ ] each other over and ruin
each other's sketches not laughing at
each other's sketches and laying them
out that kind of thing
yeah that there was like
a like a lot of politics over there and
you had to learn the politics
he hated it so did jim brewer hate him
yeah i i think yeah i didn't have a
great time there at all so those gut
shows are just so different than stand
up yeah
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify